in the distinctive style that made it
such a powerful brand Apple informed the
world it's 56 year old founder had died
writing on the company website it had
lost a visionary and creative genius and
the world has lost an amazing human
being it was a company jobs remain
dedicated to even while suffering from
pancreatic cancer returning from sickly
to introduce the iPad 2 earlier this
year
we've been working on this product for a
while and I just didn't want to miss
today so his impact on the world is
reflected on those paying tribute to him
President Obama calling him among the
greatest of American innovators CEO of
Facebook Mark Zuckerberg thanked the
father of 3 for being a mentor and a
friend and Microsoft co-founder Bill
Gates said it had been an honor to work
with him what about 2011 everybody's got
a tablet his 2011 gonna be the year of
the copycat Steve Jobs was an orphan
raised by adoptive parents in the heart
of California's Silicon Valley he
founded Apple in 1976 with college
friend Steve Wozniak he was only 21 by
1984 they produced the world's first
commercially successful computer the
Macintosh he quit after a row with the
board we're gonna take things to a whole
new level but in the mid nineties Jobs
was back heralding a bright new era for
Apple the launch of the iPod and iPhone
followed making it one of America's
biggest most profitable names when he
was unveiling a new product the insight
the excitement was absolutely incredible
and totally unlike anything else in the
world of technology and the way that
they controlled the the marketing agenda
was a crucial part in getting Apple to
where it is now
in 2004 Jobs revealed he had pancreatic
cancer the secrecy surrounding his
health continued when a news wire
service accidentally published in a bit
chewy in 2008 he did his best to laugh
it off - I just wanted to mention this
enough said
despite having a liver transplant in
2009 Jobs was forced to take him down at
sick leave at the start of this year
eventually resigning as chief executive
but the company kept on innovating just
days ago new CEO Tim Cook launched
Apple's latest offering at Steve Jobs
home in California fans laid flowers
tributes to at Apple stores like this
one in Santa Monica a recognition of the
unique abilities of a man who changed
the way we think about and use
technology